we will now go through a probability
calculation for the case where we have a
continuous sample space we revisit our
earlier example in which we were
throwing a dart into a square target the
square target being the unit square and
we were guaranteed that our dart would
fall somewhere inside this set so our
sample space is the unit square itself
we have a description of the sample
space but we do not yet have a
probability law we need to specify one
the choice of an probability law could
be arbitrary it's up to us to choose how
to model a certain situation and to keep
things simple we're going to assume that
our probability law is a uniform one so
that which means that the probability of
any particular subset of the sample
space is going to be the area of that
subset so if we have some subset lying
somewhere here and we ask what is the
probability that we fall into that
subset the probability is exactly the
area of that particular subset once more
this is an arbitrary choice of a
probability law there is nothing in our
assumption so far that would force us to
make this particular choice and we just
use it for the purposes of this example
so now let us calculate some
probabilities let us look at this event
this is the event that the sum of the
two numbers that we get in our
experiment is less than or equal to 1/2
it is always useful to work in terms of
a picture and to depict that event in a
picture of the sample space so in terms
of that sample space the knot the points
that make this event to be true are just
a triangle that lies below the line
where this is the line that x plus y
equals to 1/2 anything below that line
these are the outcomes that make this
event happen so we're trying to find the
probability of this red event we have
assumed that probe
is equal to area therefore the
probability we're trying to calculate is
the area of a triangle and the area of a
triangle is one half times the base of
the triangle which is one half in our
case times the height of the triangle
which is again one half in our case and
the end result is one over eight let us
now calculate another probability now
this is an event that consists of only a
single element we take the point 0.5 0.3
which sits somewhere here the event of
interest is a set but that set consists
of a single point so we're asking for
the probability that our dart falls
exactly on top of that point what is it
well it is the area of a set that
consists of a single point what is the
area of a single point it is zero and
similarly for any other single point
inside that sample space that we might
have considered the answer is going to
be zero let us now abstract from this
example as well as the previous one and
note the following probability
calculations involve a sequence of four
steps starting with the world
description of a problem of a
probabilistic experiment we first write
down the sample space then we specify a
probability law let me emphasize again
here that this step has some
arbitrariness in it you can choose any
probability law you like although for
your results to be useful it would be
good if your probability law captures
the real-world phenomenon you are trying
to model typically you are interested in
calculating the probability of some
event that event may be described in
some loose manner so you need to
describe it mathematically and if
possible it's always good to describe it
in terms of a picture pictures are
immensely useful when going through this
and finally the last step is to go ahead
and calculate the probability of the
event of interest now a probability law
in principle specifies the probability
of every event and there is nothing else
to do but quite often the probability
law will be given in some implicit
manner for example by specifying the
probabilities of only some of the events
in that case you may have to do some
additional work to find the probability
of the particular event that you care
about this last step sometimes will be
easy sometimes it may be complicated but
in either case by following this
four-step procedure and by being
systematic you will always be able to
come up with a single correct answer